Jimmy this year from my understanding
and from a lot of people's I think you
know like last year things started
releasing this year was psv our HTC vive
and the oculus rift all officially
launched uh you know it's kind of almost
a year that these things broke through
the door and now you're seeing VR
everywhere whereas like you know there's
there's always like skeptics I'm sure
there's still are but I don't know
myself and I think a lot more people
around the office and I think a lot more
of our audience just kind of like okay
it's here to stay like where do we go
from here is that like is that kind of
your impression too or am I just kind of
alone there what sure I think that sorry
like priority 2016 everybody thought or
like some analysts thought that 2016
would be the year of VR I think in my
eyes that's not quite the case it's more
like a slow burn than like a quick
explosion kind of thing and yeah as you
mentioned we we saw the release of all
the major you know HMDs the head-mounted
displays and um yeah I mean there's you
know start it started off with the
oculus rift I think that platform had a
really rocky launch but they just
recently released the touch controllers
which get your hands into VR and I feel
like they've been able to finish the
year strong early on they had some hmd
shipment issues that component shortages
so even if you like pre-ordered or like
back the the Kickstarter you didn't
receive it until like multiple months
later right they also like encountered a
bunch of negative press from like drm
issues and things like that things that
they backed off on but now that touches
here I think they've made up for a lot
of things and yeah Rob as you mentioned
rob was playing some of those games
earlier today I find them to be really
fun I think he was playing like superhot
VR yeah um which is a game that's
redesigned for BR it's different from
the base game and you feel like you feel
like neo from the matrix in it you know
things look slow down you can dodge
bullets you can shoot enemies and then
like their guns will fly in the air you
can catch them in their mid air cheat
them back right so that game is really
fun and then you know hot on its heels
the HTC vive released and that was the
first vr platform to allow you to like
walk around and sort
room scale environment and that was a
hundred dollars but it it is the most
sophisticated VR tracking system and
most the games that released on that
platform I would admit as a VR
enthusiast I would admit that most of
them are shovelware yeah but there are
several diamonds in the rough I think
the onward is really good a bunch of
early access stuff raw data is really
fun as well sure yeah i mean like HTC
was my favorite during preview vents
because it actually kind of made use of
the space around you i think they were
they call the chaperones that kind of
outlined the chaperones Jim I don't know
like I mean we haven't talked too much
about psv are yet but yeah of all these
platforms you have a favorite or they
kind of like obviously like as
competitors they kind of offer something
different right yes I seems the most
successful one I think they have their
strengths and advantages you know PS vr
it's it's the least robust perhaps out
of the three but it is you know the most
accessible it's it starts at three
hundred ninety nine dollars and it does
a pretty good you know it you know it's
the cheapest thing but in my opinion it
punches above its weight class a bit
considering its price tag and yeah Peter
and I talked about it a little bit and I
think before I would have liked said in
my personal opinion that the best VR
headset is the vibe but the the rift
with touch I feel like it's much closer
now and I feel like maybe the rift has
slightly better controllers but the vibe
has better tracking the better tracking
system yeah the oculus touch it kind of
like brings that more tactile feel to
the VR which is something like you're
never we're talkin bout resonable 7 and
how the fact that you know obviously
it's v art this is an obvious thing when
they touch you you're not going to feel
in the real world unless it's like
something vibrating or if something that
you're holding that's gonna react to it
sure but the oculus touch I felt like
that was much more of an actual you know
like again like this like kinetic thing
that i was using whereas you know the
HTC vive the remotes and the PS
playstation remotes didn't really do it
for me yeah so like I think the touch
controllers or they represent your hands
more whereas the PS like the PlayStation
Move and the vibe they're more abstract
they're more like things that you hold
so it's like with the vibe wands it's
like you're holding a gun or you're
holding a sword whereas the touch is
more like these are your hands
yeah and there's like quasi finger
tracking so you can like point and you
can like give the thumbs up gesture and
things like that share which helped in
like co-op games it's like a look at
that or like nice job and so forth yeah
I do want to get into you know like the
game library is the software that these
are supporting and vice versa but um
yeah like I don't know like there are
some that we'd like we seen have like
different taste Pete you've been liking
a lot of these like 3rd person games
right i mean you mentioned experiences
and stuff yes like edge of nowhere and
Chronos and things like that i like i
like a you know a broad range i think of
these games but i have you know and i
used to write off the idea of third
person stuff in VR I was like what's the
point doesn't that's not why I'm excited
about this but it turns out that like
you know great gameplay can translate
over to VR and you can benefit in ways
you know such as immersion that you know
up here in storytelling in world design
and that was the case with edge of
nowhere it was also the case with kronos
in an interesting way because that game
uses a fixed camera where every time you
enter a new room the cameras positioned
in one place or another think the
original resident evil right but your
head is the camera on that in that
regard which I found super fascinating
because I'm a big fan of that old style
so it might not be the most compelling
use of the new technology but I thought
it definitely elevated what what was
there already but you know again I think
a lot of it comes down to the platform
like I've used touch and vibe you know
in this sort of like small room scale
settings and I got agree with you like I
like the rift better in that regard and
you know like the vibe is just so hard
to set up it's such a pain in the butt
like I've gotten so close to tracing the
space like in my home and it's like oh
you're one inch off and it's like I
don't care about that one inch you care
but let me freaking play the game so I
so I find it hard there's the barrier to
entry for me to play vibe games as
higher whereas for Riften PlayStation VR
it it's very simple you know in a lot of
ways but longevity is also a thing to
and wearing the PlayStation VR headset
it's super comfortable it is all is the
most comfortable that's it yeah just you
see the other companies go for maybe the
higher specs where Sony focused in on
value but then they also were able to
nail just the ease of the use and
comfort that's pretty great so sometimes
that can dictate what type of game I
want experience
um I feel like there's there's like a
there would be like a awesome head say
if you can like combine their best
aspects like right PlayStation viewers
comfort the vibes tracking in like the
oculus rifts like controllers that would
be that'd be like perfect I know yeah
that's what I played a few preview
Venson the defense grid to that tower
defense game had this really cool like
it would give you it's being a tower
defense game you know you believe you
have a set path and there's these
minions coming through that you're
defending against and I didn't even
think about this but then once I play
doesn't that makes sense in VR which is
like I I guess a lot of these
experiences once you actually experience
it make sense but you know you have this
godlike bird's eye view of sort of the
grid itself and then you can kind of
just look down instead of having to
scroll through I keep waiting for more
people do like large-scale RTS games
yeah we're coming like Exim XCOM 2 I
think you're being one strategy games
are amazing in VR you basically play as
God and you don't have to scroll the
screen you Larry you're just above it
you look down you can instead of like
pressing a bumper or pressing like e to
rotate the map you just look around a
corner like I actually physically look
around it point to where you want these
guys to go like pick them up and drag
them I can't wait for more like things
like that you said they're coming up
yeah I can't wait for that because those
are like my most anticipated yeah I
think there's a wide variety of games
like as you mentioned like 3rd person
games that that work that I would argue
you could have it on a traditional TV
but they are more immersive envy or I
think like thumper and res like satisfy
those requirements as well like those
games can be played on TV but playing
thumper in VR is much more immersive
tight age it's um yeah it's hard to
communicate until you try it but if
you've if you ever want to feel
overwhelmed in like the best way
possible play thumper in VR yeah it
feels it feels like apocalyptic but in a
very cool edge strong way yeah it's like
you're on the front of a bullet train
it's just speeding ahead of thousand
miles an hour and a monster is staring
at you like I it's crazy yeah i'm
looking i am looking forward to next
year from what i see a lot of the games
that i've had fun with a lot of people
are having fun with and this is not a
catch-all thing I feel like the games
that were praising a lot of them are the
ones that kind of hide the limitations
of VR at this point like like thumper
like it's cool it gives you a really
good view but I feel like we're we still
haven't hit that point where
a lot of link feet were seeing VRS full
potential I'm sure it's not gonna happen
right away I think rob was playing room
in a chair which is a game that share
room I always yes I always say that I
don't know why the other one would be
more impressed yeah but that's a game
that uses room scale so it basically the
environments are all very small room
like I environm right and if you have a
room like that's big enough then then
you don't need to like teleporting tank
that so it just works within the
constraints of the game yeah and does
that horror aspects to it from what I
understand okay yeah it's or game okay
it was the res evil sevens come out and
has full PSV our sport and you can
actually just do a play through regular
on a flat screen and then you could
reload that checkpoint or go from the
next save next time you play NVR I'm
excited for that because you have to
dedicate one playthrough and commit to
VR or if you really like Vee are you
don't to commit to like you know a
single screen playthrough um I as a big
fan of horror games i still haven't
played anything that really impresses me
in the genre try this game I think what
it does well is that it takes advantage
of what VR can do so like you might turn
your head around and all of a sudden the
scene changes and you're like what is
going on but the game is about like how
you're like a psych patient you're going
crazy and our things real you don't know
and VR messes with your head
appropriately and the hole in that space
so overall what are your way to takes I
mean Jimmy you wrote the report card for
VR I don't think it's up yet it will be
up soon or is it I'm in the process of
writing cool so it'll be up soon that'll
be like more in-depth thoughts from
Jimmy but um I don't know in general I
think it's pretty good yeah i think it's
it's not it wasn't going to explode on
the scene like um like you know that we
did but I think it's more of a slow burn
and I think it has a bright future out
of it yeah p you've been optimistic
about VR for a while and it seems like
your your suspicions and your
expectations are proving fruitful uh
yeah I mean I think it's definitely
landed like it's here I don't hear
skeptics anymore like I don't feel like
there is that loud the second of the
audience being like VR stupid no one
wants it i think at this point everyone
can look at it and say yeah I've heard
this one thing as rad ore i played this
one thing and it's really rad like
everyone has a touchstone now where they
care about VR one way or another I need
people get something like Google Earth
VR not yet no but
but that's the same yes everyone says
that yeah so I want to mention quick one
quick thing about that um so that's an
app that was made by google that takes
the Google Earth API and then they like
retrofitted it to work in VR but it
feels to me like it was built for VR and
you know I was reading on on Reddit and
things like that like grown men put it
on they like fly to like where they grew
up as a kid and they sit on like they're
all rooftops and they would just start
crying um because it's just like a
nostalgia machine yeah and and I was
like that's very interesting I put it on
I did the same thing and I got very
nostalgic and yeah kind of talk about
virtual reality right i mean that's it
it's not just painting giving us a
fantastic world it's replicating i think
what you know the dream is is that
something is so convincing right and
what is more convincing than reality and
this is sort of achieved that and in a
way that it's you know the threshold is
is is hit and so we get there that's
what that's not how good it looks is it
it is yeah so it's not it's not fake I'm
right so all the stuff is actually real
rendered from like satellites yeah uh
and you can actually zoom out and see
the earth and outer space and look up at
all the stars around you and they're
real they're not like computer drawings
are actually a real life that's insane
photo telemetry man I really need to try
that out yeah so I see something like
this i think there's no way you can be
cynical about VR and this came in the
first year of this wave yeah dude given
five years give it 20 years like yeah
that I don't think anyone can be cynical
about that damn alright cool well you
know things seem to be looking up for VR
so I'm optimistic about it I still have
a lot of games to play this is the first
year we've had like an actual VR
category for end of the year if i'm not
mistaken last year again it was still
burgeoning so it seems like it's you
know starting to like you said slow burn
so look forward to that if you are
watching this after we record it live
our VR report card should be up on site
as of now so you can go read Jimmy's
more in-depth thoughts on gamespot com
you